Look at this snail he's so cute
It is so cute, oh my god
Oh when you [are] moving here all the butterflies come out. It's so cute
Oh, noo, Marzia hates butterfly what
I HATE BUTTERFLIES
And this mother duck and her ducklings
yeah they're so cute
AH
Yeah, sorry, I'm sorry. Yeah, that's adorable. Oh my God. That's so cute. How do I get a--
Hey, watch out! He peed on you!
-What's happening?
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Kill him!
I'll poop here. How do you lure him? -I don't know, we have to figure that out. Fucking idiot
Oh my God
Did you just say that for real on camera?! Is there a frog? Do I like frogs? -Yeah you do.
Oh my God, this frog is so cute!
Okay, let's catch some butterflies
You hate butterflies, right?
Right, I hate them. So let's catch them
-I know. Don't worry
And then we will eradicate them from the planet
Got one. You caught a ladybug
Do I like ladybugs?
-Yeah-- No
No? -No
EW -Okay good.
Finally you're doing something useful.
You are not funny. This is not funny.
-I'm sor-- it was just a joke for the thing, ok?
You're nothing, you're a bad boyfriend.
-I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I am-- I am [a] bad boyfriend.
I'm sorry. You're a shitty girlfriend.
You will never see this nips then.
-No, I don't-- just stop your nips, please
Okay? Thank you
What are you doing? What are you doing right now?
-Do you love me?
I-- what are you doing?
I can show you my butt
Dance, wiggle wiggle, dance, wiggle wiggle
-DAMN
Oh my God, you did so well Marzia
Thanks, I really tried hard
Um, thank you so much for playing with me today.
I play with you every day. I play with you every night.
How about for the thumbnail, we do a little kiss?
Okay yeah
-Yeah
I know y'all can't handle this shit
I know y'all gonna flag this fucking video like you always do, and I have to call google and be like
Hey, they flagged another one. Yeah, my uh my fan base is basically a bunch of pussies.
Oh, this video had blood in it. Oh, this video had nipples in it. Oh, this video was a little bit too sexual
Oh, he made me swirl. Excuse me, why don't you just go to the fucking...
Australia, like the good old days, all right. What do you--
I bet you even flagged this video already because you're triggered by my glasses
You're all a bunch of wimps. Don't flag the fucking video, alright? Stop flagging the video
I'm sick and tired of this fucking shit. Can y'all stop flagging my fucking videos?
Slop flagging the videos, God damn it. I don't make any money if you flag the video
What do you think, I do this for free?
Do you think I'm some kind of fucking charity? Do you think I do this for fun?
Do you think I do YouTube for fun?
I'm only in it for the money.
Fuck you for even thinking that, alright?
Now I gotta make this video, and it'd be great if you don't fucking flag it, alright?
DON'T FLAG THE VIDEO. So if you're not up for the challenge
Bitch
Then click the fuck away and don't flag the videe-ay (video)
Man, I should be a rapper. That was pretty good.
Oh here we are
back at it again
Holy shit. Oh my God.
I am not-- BARRELS! I hate this, oh--
Should we knock?
Yeah. Hello? [What] the fuck is this?
Hey, they got corn and everything
Hello there, Mister man. Man, you look good man.
AH! Oh
Jesus Christ, get the shit out of me.
Why is there tricycle here?
Oh, God. It's getting dark man.
It's getting well dark man.
Aww, fuck
You know shits about to go down when the drum starts hitting you.
Oh God, this is fucking creepy man. What was that?
All right but this is pretty good so far. What a nice town.
Oh my God!
(Fuck) Fuck, fuck indeed.
Oh, that's cool man. This is so fucking cool.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Hey. No. I hear you Ethan Bradberry.
What the fuck are you doing, you fucking asshole? Why you gotta be so loud man?
I ain't scared.
Oh, jeb not Fichte
Oh
Corn. I love corn, so much. Oh and climb over.
Oh thank God.
Oh
FUCK! I am so fucked! Fuck this!
RUN!
OHHHH
Oh! Oh my God.
I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine
Where, where am I?
Excuse me. I burp when I'm excited.
Marzia doesn't appreciate it. I know, but...
Whoa, it's Lickitung again.
That fucking Pokemon.
It's got Marzia.
What the fuck are those?
What the fuck is that?
Oh. Okay. No that's... great. That's funny because I was actually heading this way towards the exit. Yes.
Oh come on.
Alright, I'm out.
Poods out.
Aw shit, I ran out of batteries.
(LEFT VIDEO) Not sure if I should run downhill.
That seems like a bad-- What was that?
What the fuck is out there? Oh God.
This is fucking creepy man.
Oh shi-- okay, okay. Ah, okay
AH! Oh, Jesus Christ.
You scared the shit out of me cactus.
MY NEW COMPANY, B3
Big Bouncy Boobies.
Alright who's got the biggest titties?
Flat chest. Zoey, get the fuck out!
Get the fuck out, Zoey!
Keana...
You got that ass, but get out!
What fuck do you take me for?!
We're called the Big Titty Titties.
Nikki, you look like you're from Tumblr.
I despise you. I hate your guts.
But business is business, and you're hired Nikki.
Billy, you're in.
Okay, we got Lilanni. She's Asian, fla-- FLAT CHEST?!
Lilanni! Why are you show up even?! Get out! Alright, Zoe-- ZOEY! We had this talk before!
It's time to hire another one.
Okay, we got Lillian. She's a teen. Tattoos
Fuck off, fuck off Lillian. Why is it so hard?
Alright, we're hiring her. You better get some implants. Alright, what's her cup size? B, that's--
Where are all the big breasted women? FINALLY!
A gift from the Gods, Candice!
You're in.
Fuck sake, you're all useless. One dollar per hour. Keana, you're in. Tiffany, one dollar an hour.
Tiffany, you're in.
You're in. Now buy me shoes. Oh my God, Zoey. How many times are you trying?
How many fucking times I gotta tell you, Zoey?!
Get the fuck out, and stop wasting my time!
You got zero potential! ZERO
Hey Tiffany, wear this butt plug while you go shopping.
-Give it to me.
Mmmmmmmmmmmmm
Butt plug. Alright Zoey. You wanna work in this business so hard? Here take this butt plug.
Find me some cigarettes. Fuck off. I'm gonna have to hire my last girl Marlena. -Naturally.
But she said naturally. But ain't nothing natural about that girl.
Oh my God that money
Finally! Finally I'm rolling the pimp business. My mom would be so proud of me if she looked at me right now
The way I handle women with such dignity and respect. Even Tumblr would approve of this video.
HAIL TO THE PIMP KING PEWDIEPIE
PIMPDIEPIE BITCH! THAT'S ME MOTHERFUCKER
You bros voted
If I was an Anime character, what would I be?
An anime schoolgirl
You hear that Easley? I'm an anime schoolgirl. Thanks to you bros voting on Twitter. Thank you so much.
There's so many cool animes, but anime school girl.
Just what I wanted.
Thank you. Appreciate it. So thanks to Crunchyroll,
we're bringing that to life.
But that's what this video is going to be. But first, for those of you who don't know about crunchyroll
It's a streaming service of anime and drama.
It's a service that I personally use as well,
So I'm really happy to have them [as] a sponsor and making this Pewdiepie anime a real thing.
Huge thanks to them.
I'm a fan of anime myself. What can I say?
I enjoy a good Berserk.
[I] sound like a mom trying to say like,
"Yeah, I watch anime."
I enjoy a good GTO. Really great shows.
They're all available on Crunchyroll, and I would love to hear your bros opinion on them. So check them out.
They have over 25,000 anime episodes, so I'm sure you'll find something that you'll enjoy.
But not just that, you're supporting the Japanese anime industry by supporting Crunchyroll.
Cause every season, they're bringing in the freshest anime straight from Japan.
So basically, if you check out the link in the description, crunchyroll.com/pewds
You get a 30-day free trial to check it out,
and see if you like it.
You basically can watch as much anime you want
for 30 days with no ads, 1080p baby,
And the newest episodes air one [hour] after they are up in Japan with professional subtitles.
I think that's pretty cool. I really enjoy it,
so maybe you will as well.
And thanks again for Crunchyroll for making this happen. Now, let's roll the clip
Huh?
Hey, what you doing?
Not much, just hanging.
*laughs*
Grrrrrrrrr
Hey, what are you guys talking about?
Oh, hi. Just chatting about the big game tonight.
Why do you care what we're talking about?
I was just trying to talk to--
-We all know you're obsessed with him.
Everyone sees you taking photos of him everywhere.
No, I don't!
Why don't you just leave him alone for once?
He'll never be yours. Get over it.
HYAAAHHHHH *slaps*
Alright girls. Take it easy now.
HYAAAHHHHHH *kicks*
Ah
HYAH!
He's not yours. You'll never come even close to what I feel for him.
Feel this, you little rat.
NOOOOOOOOOOOO! T_T
This is all your fault!
You... will... regret this.
HYAAAHHHHHHHHH
Any last words, little freak?
Suck on my laser, BITCH
AHHHHHHHHH
She was right. I'll never have him, but if I can't have him
I must become him
What is this game?!
Sup, bro.
You know what 'sup' brother. It's been eight days, and you still haven't recalibrated your puzzles.
What are you even doing?
-Hey, take it easy. I gotten a ton of work done today.
A skeleton
*laughs*
*laughs some more*
Ahh, I will attend to my puzzle. As for your work, put your little more 'backbone' into it.
NYEEEHHHHH
Hey
*laughs*
I am a ghost that lives inside a dummy. Human, I'll scare your soul out of your body.
Oh God, it's one of those meanies.
I got knives
Damn boy, you fucking hardcore man
I'm... out of knives.
Now, I hate making promises, but the promise I made to her
You know what would have happened if she hadn't said anything, buddy?
You'd be dead where you stand.
Hey lighten up, bucko. I'm just joking with you. Besides, haven't I done a great job protecting you?
I mean, look at yourself. You haven't died a single time.
Hey, what's that look supposed to mean? Am I wrong?
So Stefan, you bring your hands up to begin to concentrate
Coalescing the Arcane energy into the strange dull glow of green in your hands as the swirl continues to spiral
You shoot your hands forward releasing this burst of corrosive energy towards the female
It's been a while since you've used this explosive power in this town in your eagerness
You weren't paying attention to your target
The arrow arcs to the side, missing your target and instead striking Kaleem in the back of the shoulders
No, not Kaleem!
I'm sorry Kaleem!
I tried to help.
What are you doing noob?
I'm sorry Kaleem!
And even trying to put him out of his misery, you managed to pierce him with the rapier because he's not moving
But you don't reach any vital organs. So now you're just adding more pain to his slowly sizzling misery
Kaleem!
I'm sorry Kaleem!
You have no idea what this building is.
-Is this even a building? What is this?
As you shout that out Stephan, you turn around and look up and immediately see a sign hanging over the door that says
Uhhh
'Butcher'
Ohh. How did you not notice that Cinderella?
-What? Notice what?
Look at the sign right there.
-What sign?
It says 'Butcher'.
-No it doesn't.
Jesus Christ. Just let me do this for you.
The door clicks and opens up into a dark interior.
You have that light spell still?
-I already used it Ken. I can't be bothered to do it again.
Actually for light spell, you can do an infinite number of times.
Yeah, I know. Okay, I'll do a light spell in Rainbow color.
-Okay.
A very beautiful,
Very beautiful array of rainbow colors streaks across the room. You can now see indeed, this is a butcher shop.
Uh, there is a large--
-A fabulous butcher shop
Dead unicorns everywhere
Okay, where's the-- where's the blood going?
-This is the part where I say let's just go back.
Okay, can I cast a rainbow spell to... make this situation a little nicer?
You can. You cast your light spell [of an] array of beautiful colors, lighting up the tunnel.
As you guys not so quietly turn the corner with this vibrant bright rainbow light, expelling from the front of Stefan's quarter staff,
the large figure pulls its hood back,
and you can see what looks like
A snarling ogre-face standing about 12 to 13 feet tall.
Its head is bulbous and mutated like some sort of pulsating creature has taken root on the right side of its face.
Its eyes beeline unnatural intelligence for its kind
You dare interrupt our sacred gifting ceremony
I will know your names and intent
So we might whisper them to the silent screamer and crush your memory on this world.
And with that, we will leave this game on a cliffhanger
Dun dun dun~
-Wha-- Noo, are you serious?
*laughs*
I was so into it
Uhhh, Can we loot Kaleem?
Look at my creepy little fish arms.
You are so cute.
-Oi, come here daddy.
My sweet child.
-Oh my God, your knees are in your chest.
Yeah, if you look down your face like wasn't your chest and your knees are already in your chest
Oh, there's a-- there's a... strange object here.
Which is... Oh God!
This is very...
-Are you serious?
This is very inappropriate. -You put down the strange rubber object. Can I pick it up?
Daddy wins!
Daddy wins.
-Wait, daddy wins?
Rematch. Hit rematch.
-Bleach! I found bleach!
NO! NOOO, NOOOOO! DADDY WON.
-Drink soap. Drink bleach.
DON'T DRINK THE BLEACH!
WHOA, WHOA.
-Oh God, whoa!
How did you--
Ha ha ha ha! Do it again, do it again!
-Do that again!
I wanna fly, daddy!
-I don't know how I did it. You went inside it.
I got a fork! I got a fork. I can stab a bitch.
-Let go of the fork, Timmy.
No, no, let-- give me-- give me the fork.
-Put the fork down!
Come here daddy! Time to stab you with a fork.
-Okay.
Oh god, there's an electrical cabinet there.
I gotta pro-- NO.
Timmy. No. NO.
TIMMY!
-Yeaaahh!
Look, you're trash
Who are we in the trash? Oh, I want to go into twice. Hey, you are going [to] trash going
I want to go. It's [close]. You're going to trade. Yeah you go dead brick. Yeah
That's really nice. Yes. He closed it I
Mean gosh this traffic, huh?
when game is clearly Fallen
10 or 10 10 out of 10 again
first idea around 10 IMDb
Oscar
rotten Tomatoes
Flawless game Polish game
Flawless drafting ah love it. Oh
Minute can I interest you in a bucket perhaps?
What's that sound could it be?
found [Regal]
Thanks surgery go sing
[alright], [alright], Iran-Iraq
Really them completed
Hello
This is y'all God. It's actually fucking creepy
[cop]
[upset] your birthday. Oh
my God, oh
God, I'm actually terrified what the fuck caliphate. What are you know in age anything? What day are you?
Yeah, Dada Da
Dada
da Da oh
Bow wow, what are yelling at me right?
Back what is that bag? What bitch man leave me alone?
Bro, it's just a prank
the cameras right there
Bro, the cameras right there
There's just a prank bro. It's just a prank
Don't you like?
Pranks, bro, I guess you don't like prank. I stole your car. Just a prank, bro
I'm fucking your wire just a prank bro. [I] give you just a prank, bro
It ruined your life, just a prank, bro
Chance you people
understand
Just a prank bro. [it's] just a prank the cat, right
the cameras right there
you can tell my
Don't you like [briggs], bro? I guess you don't my brain
I've got your fire just a prank bro. I'm [gonna] [tell] [you] [how] [to]
grow [your]
[shit] right what that wasn't a prank though?
Can't you people?
Understand that it's just garlic
and
fucking fine
[that's] why it's okay
It's just a prank
Just to break the cameras right there
It's just a prank bro. It's
Just a prank
the cameras right there
Bro, the cameras right there
And just a prank bro. It's
Just a prank
Don't you like pranks, bro? I guess you don't like [pain]
In the beginning it was nothing well accidents a lot of stuff rafi. It was boring and then
There was the broken podcast [a] long time the [sexist]
We know his kid on the other the American get a cinnamon toast [can]
And the podcast is so good it brought light into this dark and toxic world
focus that's a bit intense don't you think
Anyway, if welcome special guests like markiplier
jacksepticeye Crime and International Rockstar, President Obama
That last one it's a wash they were cake
challenges and
Conversation so legendary that the animals still sing of their glory
whatever
Now we're [broken] Podcasters making history once again
Coming with sling TV
So get ready to experience of throw fists like you've never
experienced before
And you better watch because if you don't then the robot will win that last one is also a lie
Maybe the broken [Podger]
Available now on [Fling] TV
ah
Yes, oh
Yes, say my Santa Claus. I think I'm Santa Claus so what would Santa Claus do in a situation like this I?
Would steal all their shit boom that's my bicycle
This is my TV santa needs [gift] [-] what else do we need Christmas pudding [all] year?
That's my Christmas pudding no no not what else. [oh] money money money money money money money money money so much money
Oh my God. There's the painting there this ugly ass painting yes. I mean, it's probably worth a fortune dude
Okay, oh
God they're coming. [oh], God they're coming
I've got a bit of height. I better hide in the closet
Thank God
[haha]
Oh my God, Tom could Tom could stop stop Tom Cruise. Tom cruise. [he's] fitting the shit out of me
[haha] run run run run run run [run]
I'm sorry
Who would beat up Santa?
[whoo-hoo], I'm an everyday thief thief. No, I'm [scent]
I'm ten
Towers reverse gifting I was gift [traversing] have you never heard of that you take shit from people?
It's great hey Tom. It's me. [I] got all [your] shit. [Tom's] tone doesn't know what to do
[I] got all [your] shit what you gonna do about it bitch wow in your face Tom cruise in your face
Oh my God
That was [amazing]
What trip don't give me that look oh?
He's here what you said? He's coming an hour from now. [no], he's right on time
[Gonzalo] hey, it's been too long man. Hello honey. I sell melons
Would you like to buy?
Yes, not
Come on, man. Let me angles all right. Whatever did - yeah yeah, yeah, yeah, where's the wine? No? No here? We are
[boys] Gonzalo, all right guys this has been great by the way, you look fabulous
Oh, why did you say so girl?
Hey, I know I'm fabulous. I can't dare you over. How fab I am
Anyway, I can't remember
Vault I like your bones. I'm not
On your balls, right?
All right, I'm gonna go to the Canteen. [oh] gonzalo. [are] you trying to leave the room again?
Well, well, just come back to the living room. What screwing around?
You guys are mean okay? No really don't come and get me Joe come on
We really just want you to come back in here. Fuck you. You know what no comes on
[no], that's up. You need to be went through the wall
Yeah, superpowers we invited you over, but this is just no let me go you demon
You Demon hunter fuck you
Fuck off
people piece of shit
God damn it. I know I should just take the wine and left
She's here
Ginevra, and yeah, I've been so long since we've seen you
How are you doing? I'm pretty good. Thank you
Ginevra damnit, I missed my hi. How are you? I am. So happy to see you after so [long]
That's funny. I said the same thing
hilarious
Hey, how's it going? My name is?
Don't be a solid be the best goddamn broccoli. You could ever be
you can make fun of me if you make fun of my hair, but if you make fun of my hair
I'll fucking stab a bitch
No diving. You can't tell me what to do
Well shit, [spike] my back you have permission to let it okay
Bye bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Oh
Yeah, Mac that bitch
I have the power of Japheth in my hand
Nothing in life will ever be the same after that you're missing your met your miss. [oh]
No, let it go let it go
Alright fries that [will] be it yeah
another survival zombie multiplayer game on steam early access with
microtransaction
Hey, you know what I'm sorry it might actually be good. [I] don't want to be the guy who just judged shit
I want to be respectful, and I want to give this game the best chance it could possibly deserve. Let's do this
Are you?
We're gonna fucking wait and play these fucking piece of fucking shit. I'm gonna get my 15 pounds of fun
It's the last thing I'll ever do oh
It's it
What?
Today, we're Gonna do that what's in your backpack?
They told me I couldn't build a medieval my God
[anyway] cross I never I never seen art in such a profound way
until I played viking McDonald's
simulator 2015
Are these the meat? Oh jesus man? I know how to [fish] some bugs man. Jesus look at night
We Gonna make a fearful little burger bad [Abadan] don't just make further
Make life any a vote no, okay?
[five]
What did you do all these burgers are burnt? They look like hockey pucks make it the burger on the leg clint
Goddamn rat I'll get you one day. I'll get you I'm gonna fucking murder you. Oh, oh, hey
That's our let's don't worry. That's just our pet claps
What the fuck are you you're making a bad rex?
Our intern is mentally challenged now all our ingredients are
Fucking dirty are fucking dirty man clap
Some say if the meat looks like a hockey puck you shouldn't need it. I say
Yolo, it's like an oreo great not so this is my specialty I call it cancer in a burger
I
Gotta Follow with my burger oh
What is this shit? We thought? I'll guess [get] it who thought that was a good idea
I'll go advertise good be naked sex [day] itself what an intern doing?
intern intern oh
trying to break free I
Have a new bucks to fight the other box
Glass why you leaving? Why are they leaving? What's wrong with our [phones] cannot yeah, I'm coming with [cellphone]
This game is like Skyrim. Hey, how's it going bros? My name [is]
[-] my favorite game of all time and judah is stimulators whoa. I'm in here now. I
Can [what]?
you see why I [say] it's my favorite game because I can change my
underpants, I'm going for the striped ones because the stripes shows up the curse of the girls but
Let's go to school. So what our plan for this?
Episode is to make someone fall off this roof get amazing size boobs make a chan
So does the other girl a real laughing and having fun?
For all having fun, right?
so much fun, dry
So anyway about that tampon, how do I get it out?
All right, so here apparently you can use drop on people
If they don't see you, and I obviously have amazing sugoi Desu or chan
Panties, I mean sneaking skills you haven't been acting as your usual self lately let's go down here [mon]. Thank you Mr.. Chad
[no] my gosh
Well, it's nothing
If you don't want to talk about it, that's fine
Henderson my mom died. What's that some drinking alone?
Sometimes when he's drunk. [he]
comes into my [room] and
luckily
for me from
an
Almost evening transplant is good at all
[basically] pay
For walking near semis presents 4 p.m.
Where the fuck is she I?
Let some bitch
Where is she?
their shit no one can see me I
am the Danger
Alright
justice
[wow]
Alright friends thinking. I'm saying that if you're so there this game is so awesome
I can't wait to play more ones to get updated trust me you know this video
Now's a great time to leave a like and [I'll] see you in the next one. It's always stay awesome Pros
Flip flip baby girl flip over table get points don't learn at a time
This one will go to hell, bitch. I love you, please don't kill me shut up [your] table ah
You it all may
pick up nice whoo
hey, buddy, ah
[stop] start fighting crap. Hey look at me sexy. Sexy. Sexy
Come on. Let's go in play. Wait a minute. I want [to] go in a bit. You want a big message guys
she's coming in the same a
business in
failure to explain
[that] we're gonna be simply crying. Oh God. Yeah, do you [want] it?
Let me go let me go [oh]
I killed your father
ah
I
live in uncertainty every day
Every time I look at myself in the clear cool waters of Africa. I expect to see a beautiful giraffe staring back at me
But all I see is the taco lover [I] was lost without hoping this desolate [word]
Why would mother Earth so cruel as to not grant me with the Noscopes? I so desperately deserved and
also
the body of A giraffe
hello, my name is Falcon, Lord x x x x x
Hello
hello, my name is Falcon, Lord x x x capital x x x x I am a trans be she's
Human - Giraffe the Wide Fields of Africa is where I belong, but yet
Why do I feel so lost [I]?
Think of the Falcon lovers of the world and how they have taken me so far
but even I would only have 3 subs instead of three thousands if it weren't for
M
Did you see the way he yells into his microphone as he plays games?
The way his Golden hair falls like waves over his sky-blue eyes
It makes me want to cry
[Pierce's] [my] Senpai and I the co I who he will never notice I sigh in the wondering hole
Listening to the far-off sound Development and gazelles roaming the sun-Soaked plains
The sounds of Africa are so peaceful
contradicting my thunderstorm of feelings
Why won't you ever noticed me?
yes, he has made videos acknowledging my existence, but I was nothing more than a laughingstock to him a joke [a]
Falcon losers who would want anything to do with me?
Suddenly a loud, cry pierce's my eardrum who wants to do this
Ha ha ha [I] think isn't it supposed to be you oh
I think it'd [be] fun if you try to be me let's have a pew deal. Let's do it. All right [ok] you go first
Are you working for the barrels all right? This is my money
Are you working for the barrels? Uh looks like you're good Martin. Yeah, buddy. Good job
Eric Marshy
I
Blink that's a [million] [voices]
The way the volume of the tone almost gave me a freaking heart attack
creepy
No, I think
Shaking my head. It's definitely not better increase the Noscopes I guess
It is [peary] pack
Immediately I stand and spin around
Running towards the stands what if he shocks me? He'll be surrounded by lions trying to fight them off with his laptop damn it
You're fighting a lion you're like damn it
Kids cried after smacking one of the lions upside the head [and] seeing it was unharmed goodbye I cry
[Imma] save him. I bring it to action brushing over and making my prince trapped cause
[just] possibly lion tears start bleeding and they run away living [Pierson] the grand I
Rush to Pierce and kneel before him
Hey, Perry pass
I am a yellow
Cherry pie. [oh] yeah, hey Pete pie groans
Calculus your desk yeah
It's me. I just can't let it get it. I cried Sparkly enemy tears falling from my face I
Love you
It's miles. I love you
did
Heavenly we embrace and my one dream [has] [come] true. I
Have to turn into a duck cry went over to pewds and said it's okay
come
I'll take you to my dear home
How many [songs] more traumatic I liked it?
He carefully worked in Little [cubes] into his arms and started walking [few] looked at cry with big eyes. He you know
We have known it for a long time now
We started to suspect something when you try to hook up with a swine if you started blushing. [I] was dead time passed. He
Scored they walked him together in Christ said come on egg dinner
He suddenly got an evil looking face, but peace did not [tear] he was so in love with the strong white man
man
Z snap
Ending in this brother. I love you
that cry updated when to the kitchen
He did not say [anything] when [cuse] walked in cry turns around slowly. He was creepy and scary
What eat he said as he waved with an knife and a fork he's backed off, cry
Whoa, what are you doing? I suddenly wanted to have duck for dinner
Pew started to walk a little bit faster backwards in Christ's wallet, and the way he knew it - you started running
Why are you chasing me crying? I thought you loved me. I love duck [screamed]
Really [my] way you have to yell. I loved I loved our key screams. Loud. Is that good well?
It's not like you're narrating [which]
[I'm] [glad]
That's it perfect Jews went to the bathroom
But there were no places to run or cry
What what why was during or their pews went to the bathroom?
But there are no places to run or and then christ smashed into the [TV] idea
Which is if like christ machines [his] doors I impacted you as you're like mid-sentence. That's so intense
Wow, I am such an intense person then again
She twins in the bathroom, but there were no places to run or I smashed in the door
I like suck salty
He was this thing pure sad place to go go toilet
[he] jumped up on the toilet seat pulled the lever and flushed himself down he tried to hold his breath
But he got choked by the water anyway. Oh, no, but suddenly he felt ere. He could breathe he took deep breath [oh]
What I want a lower board there
Where I am [I]?
You're in the third stupid an Italian voice that kind of sounds Italian said could it be the other true. [love] [is]
Define how puce tried to look after a little gold Tim statue in the dark, but couldn't see anything
also, [Parody] long time no see
Many Years ago in a kingdom called bro lots. They lived their brave knights by the name of sir
Pewdiepie he was [king] enters and [queen] Myers most valuable [night] from the square table
One Day king Dead [Cos] [summoned] sir Pewdiepie to his chamber to ask for a favor
They're paired Apply both
I and queen Maya believe that you are the only person we can trust with this mission
You must find the sword named Stephano and use it to slay the dragon Cryotic king and car instructed
It's a hurdle saying the dragon cry a dick only a Madman would do such a thing
at first the Pewdiepie refused vigorously
But then king Ed car said something that sparked his interest
If you successfully slayed the dragon and save the princess locked in the tower
You will be able to marry her
How could he resist such an offer everyone knew the princess looked in the tower was the most beautiful princess in all of the land?
Skin like Ivory eyes the color of chocolate and a lovely deep voice
I will find a sword slay the dragon and save the princess before sundown tomorrow
Sir, Pewdiepie proclaimed
Throwing his fist in the air as if the battle had already been won
I am glad to hear it the [King] said with a smile
but please allow me to send you with a few others for backup and
this backup happened to me [Machia] A
Beautiful and talented alchemist who knew her way with Magic and the would L. Come quick what?
Yeah
It makes you sound like she knows her way with Magic and me like
See how I just read [that], huh?
that ruby off [ok]
this backup happened to be [Marcia] A
beautiful and talented alchemist who knew her way with Magic and the wood Elf Martin
The trek to find the sword was long in peril many trials and tribulations [stand] in their way
The pit of doom the tomb of Malice and even the fears of fabulous
but nothing stood in the way of serb ewdiepie and his crew he reached the large rock that held the mighty swords to Harden and
grasp it handled victoriously, [I]
Their purity pie of bro [alert] proclaim distorted mine
he yelled as he pulled at the sword and pulled at the sword and
Holdeth the sword again no matter how many times he tried the sword was not budge
Marzia walked up from the weapon and swiftly pulled it out with one tug before handing it to the night
Oh, wait. Is this your only lying. Yeah, this is it
It's why one way do I need to sound like very like really found really chipper
Yeah, you gotta be a little hell, man. What a jovial sight to see sir, Pewdiepie. Are you not the strongest in the land?
[you're] way too good [at] [that]. Okay. That was fine
[alright]
We shall see who's strong when I play the dragon
he proclaimed they traveled another few weeks before reaching the castle with a princess live they snuck through the gate and
met with a
300-foot horror that was the cry of a dragon, so
She's hanging out. You know all right here. We go
They raised [our] weapons and stared into the white paint of the dragon before charging at full speed
Christ them because he knew all too well of the break tight spot
I'm glad you came. I love swedish meatballs for dinner then quiet mode yet
What [if] what I spit?
You fucking call this grass. That's the worst grass. I've seen in my life. Are you fucking kidding me? What you doing - you?
Wouldn't stop twitching you goddamn cow all right, so we have [some] demon cows in a grass simulator game
great
Just what I had [have] [stopped]. Oh, God. This is terrifying all right. You know what I'm going in no more grass for me
[oh], God, the grass is everywhere all right everywhere make the gret a
Gun really like hey. Go shoot the grass ['red]
Take this fred. You'll never get me ah infinite demo
Slow-mo shooting that grand
360 360 Noscope [alright], the grass is still alive. I don't know what to do. I should the cows. I'm sorry Demon cow
You fatty oh can't kill them can kill the devil, huh?
oh
Hagrid smirk and looked up from the buffet of firm tight Flesh
That lays spread Edge before him to kill his head question me what the fuck's
Ready [Gali]
Hahaha, Dumbledore grinned he has been very good. He said thoughtfully
Tracing the crease of [Harry's] hurt ours for the fingertip. I think he deserves both our [cocks]
Harry [Battles] something incoherent with the frantic movement of it communicated his approval
for a long moment the older [man] lost himself in familiar tastes our God then the sound of an indignant and
neglected harry broke you through their [life] driven snogging friend well someone just
Be already
Haggard and Dumbledore chuckled as dumbledore picked up his one releasing harry's bonds before he cast lubrication spells harry gasps
Then he yelps [oh] when he felt rough hands all him to his knees and the blunt tip of nudging the entrance to his body
[Agri] shudder to his own relief after harry sucked him down to the base and swallowed heard around the saw
everybody
He whimpered as harried hands laid between his legs here one
chelated [B], and
Yay
I'm not Gonna life and that was weird
Mr.. Krabs, that's Dr.. Kran excuse me very much. I [thought] [oh] look there's so many of them. You're so Kawaii
[I] have a doctorate [I] don't deserve [that] we can spend it
Look at that doctor crap. I get murdered your entire family. How does that make you feel?
Who's the doctor [now] [wouldn't] you say that if you're such a good doctor then why is your family net?
All right, that was pretty dark and horrible. Oh
bitch ass bitch
Ryan Factory
FBI FBI FBI
you
Take a crap [oh]
Yeah, shop. Let's chop down his palm. Tree. Well. It looks like it's [crew] is erecting are you?
This one goes out to all of y'all who are struggling to get High views on YouTube?
I'm about to tell you the secret that no one knows about to accept me as I just figured it out
Listen carefully boys and girls. Hey
Yo, [which] the number one cycle never back and sit down relax here have a spirit cut a Mountie sticks
I compare my grandma swag, but we're getting up to track the song is about Iraq
[no]
I'm not talking about the nation I'm here to tell you all about the great
Innovation if you refresh your videos [the] more you confuse that you might be introduced to might come to you. We all been there
We all have struggles you try to paper [sub] they get to another scrub your how to do class
But they just give you subscribe you can a false flag and your master pong tag. What's a bigger?
Do you give you so much be a trick are they part of looming not in no its way that can be your they work
Really hard. Do they come here?
No
You got it all wrong if you [latinas] hit us in the top L bitch put some boobs in the thumbnail bed
Get the money yeah really fucking quick get the boots and a thumbnail bitch no, I can't do that
It's not very nice [poor] monster. You got to go buddy Christ's birth to the thumbnail bitch put the movement
It's all now back okay, okay? I'm sorry. Sorry the trick is simpler
I learned from the plant to take your lies within the 90-foot events cast you may want to consider having implants
You may Wanna consider having em okay? I don't get me wrong
[I'm] not being as long as you have hope they don't matter what your sexy with juniors ethnic unity, [okay]?
Nobody's gonna click on that shit come on man. That's issues
You could later have an iMplant you should consider having implants everybody you should consider having implants
You should consider having implants never coming to commit are you gonna be a bitch or you gonna? Make people click on that jiggly?
Yes
[just] think of all the views I know you want to get it and add it and make a trial your occupancy wedding
person the Thumbnail
Boobs and a [thumbnail] bad get the money up really fucking quick get the [boobs] and a thumb nail bed for what about my integrity?
Just kidding as [notice] I can put a bumpy boobie move to the top [down] there put the moves on the top now bad
man, everybody you should
But I'm a boy. I don't want it
and the
where
[there]
Erbs boobs
burps yeah
That's right. I killed robocop. How you ask lactation
When I was keeping an acid white people turning to black people
[I] have the best what don't you [want] to find in your Kung Pao chicken?
[10:04], I don't love it
In Michael [Jackson's] final moments he thought about Justin Bieber
For my next trick. I will pull a saxophone solo out of an erectile dysfunction
Erectile dysfunction mean you can get a boner
instead of coal Father Christmas obviously [bad] children that's
funny
what did the us and drop drop to this children now in Afghanistan is going to be bad a
Cooler full of Morgan
if you have to be for
Sarah hell yeah, we got Natalie Cartman finally. What are they doing the Natalie portman?
on the third day [of] Christmas
And [you're] [said] to me the recipe for
Methamphetamine on
the second day of Christmas
Segar sent to me
To leave your batteries and the recipe for [Madame] feta mean on the third day of Christmas
[and] your son to me
three litres Matches on two lithium batteries and the recipe for Madame feta mean
on the fourth day of
Christmas and your son to me
four cans of hydrochloric acid 3 [litres] of acetone to leave your batteries and the recipe for
Methamphetamine on
The fifth day of Christmas and you're sent to me five top top singers
For cancer hydrochloric acid 3 litre that [is] [on] two lithium batteries and the recipe [from] [that] embed of me
on
The sixth day of Christmas and you're sent to me
six chicken bucket five
chopped off fingers
For cancer particle [recanted] three leaves about the tone to VP batteries and the recipe for Madam better me
On the seventh day of Christmas, and you're sent to me
seven Grand in Cash six chicken buckets five
chopped off fingers
for cancer my decor cat said three lose message on to leave your batteries and the recipe for
Methamphetamine on
the eighth [day] of
Christmas Edgar said to me eight picks on my mom seven grand in cash six chicken buckets five
chopped off fingers
For chemspider chloric acid [3] [litres] of acetone to leave your batteries and the recipe for Madam better me
on the ninth day of
Christmas and you're sent to me nine
Mexicans and coats eight pics of my mom seven grand in cash six chicken buckets five chopped off fingers
four cats of hydrochloric acid two three liters of acetone to lithium batteries and the
recipe for Methamphetamine
the tenth Day of Christmas
Edgar sent to me
Ten Dead prostitutes nine Mexicans and [coats] a pic to my mom
seven Grand in cash six chicken bucket five [chop] Stop fingers
for catified Sarcastic three leaves the best account you'll ep a-- batteries and the recipe for
methamphetamine
On the Eleventh day of Christmas and you're sent to me Eleven cops shooting ten Dead
prostitutes nine mix against and codes eight [picks] my mom seven grand in cash six chicken bucket five
chopped [off] fingers
forecast by the car cast a three Levi's the tone to lithium batteries and the recipe for
methamphetamine
On the twelfth day of Christmas and gert said to me. He made me a bitch and now he calls me Jesse
How's the [Cobras] bad back? Hope you bros enjoy that Christmas special?
It was made by cypher den she did an amazing job so go check out our channel. [I] leave a link here
Go subscribe and tell her I sent you [brooch]
Have a great Christmas if you don't celebrate Christmas have a happy holidays or happy whatever you'll be doing
[thank] you so much for this amazing year and
I want to thank you all for for being there. Here's the brofist for many more brush stay awesome
This ever happen to you
Are you peeing on me eat? Well? What are you gonna? Do about it nothing? [he's] like
Luckily I find this tutorial on how to draw a horse hopefully that'll help
All right for the final step I got [damn] [it]. I am a vegetarian, but I want to eat your face
Hello 9-1-1
report a vegetarian
Yes, yes, he is trying to eat my face. Oh wait
I was supposed to get one of the drinks at her dad damn it
Which one [that] I put the drugs in I got yeah, but I forgot
How about a drink both, but I need to know if you're the chosen one
That I asked it's holy
How can see if I have 26 million subscribers while there's only them in 280?
Million people at Earth [fake] a cunt. [I] I don't know how to explain that to you you might just die from a brain fart
Here we are running in a horror game again. When are they gonna start putting checkpoints in [the] game?
Find a note must be a note
you think being the much bribe bitch and YouTube would have
All right, there's the preferred let's go to the [cooper] the Cooper is dancing
laughs
Okay, Darsh line
My God, there's still hope for us. There's still hope [for] our cake let it go let it go man
Yeah
Yeah, oh my God. I got a high fly myself a cad come to retire. I'm Krista, bitch I
Can't I can't believe I saw Kim Kardashian?
Good for you good for you
You're sucking today, [and] [it's] pretty good for you good for you
Get you again for you good for you
Good for you
You're trying it all right. You know what we're gonna. Have to expand here. I think it's not time that we chose them
Yes, oh my God, it's Gonna be awesome
I got it
No, why did I do that no [lacey]? What are you doing here?
[oh]
God - is missing now where where ah?
We're always there oh
Hey author, how are you doing?
Going out for a midnight snack
Well, this is the restroom you moron some fucking go to the restaurant
Idiot you have beautiful eyes author but seriously no midnight selfie, please [oh]
God, [where's] she oh?
for the love of dicks
moving
And I'm moving so far. What is missing?
one it's
method where hey
Hey, ha ha how you doing [there] [chap]? [oh], [God] where did he go?
Yeah, bloody fixed on Bangla
[wait], fuck you fuck off. Whoa. Well. What's [the] fucking guy?
What the fuck are you?
There more than no, oh God no. Oh, [God] no, oh, [God] oh
That is some creepy shit, man. You cannot come in and eat here. No you can
You bitch go home. You're drunk
Stop go home. [oh]
oh, oh
oh
That's great. [I] want to go home now. I'm pretty sure that whatever they paying me here is not worth it. [oh]
Let's get ekg, and we did your nose beautiful song ever we knew every
Noise [no] one can remember how you sounded great my thank you thing
You should be thinking you should expect everything and can't it
With [pity] no, I just can't give up
Hope you got what you [pay] [me] my mom
Wow, what the fuck is wrong with me the statistic called nightmare generator ow
[ah]
Ha for the love of God this game. I didn't ask for this
That one [deer] jumping [guy] gave it I fucking hate you [Pde] pie
You're a fucking asshole with gay fight you hair you can make fun of me
You can make fun of my hair, but if you make fun of my hair, I'll fucking stab a bitch free pie. You suck
And you swallow
ah
It's a wonderful morning
The sun is shining the birds are tweeting
their bad get off my jock [oh]
Oh, no - did a little spastic to work there for a second. That's beautiful
Hold me back up stead
Hello
Lady protect me fuck if you don't even like [jd] [me] [I'm] [Eddie] here. What do you want a die, bro?
Do you want it? That's cDS as a necklace?
That's adorable
Where did you get it? Take my knees witness never fucking learn let's?
Go [for] more XD
Well, I don't much mushrooms. [oh]
my God
I'm up here now. What am I doing here crying? I don't know. What are you doing up there?
What have you done bro? Go through a
Okay, Pal, please no wait. I'm good
All right, fine, okay
Where am I going? Oh, okay? Okay? You shoot that portal there
I'm sick up to there no no, no I got a platform. [I] got a plan oh, we don't know yeah
I got a plan ready. Oh, we gotta do this little bit less than Omega [I]
got
[earlier] no, you should pull a little brother
[shoop] [shoop] forell listen to me good father
Listen to me no no no no shit porter. See you don't even know what you're talking about
[I] said no no no no no no no that don't know me. No, no your blood
You should have all that [you] [sure] [about] [that]. You sure you sure you sure
You sure you sure your leash shot your stooges. You shoot good
I will cry cry cry cry cry. [do] you remember?
What?
September
It did [oh], they're just thing over [here] and see that you see this I do actually
oh
Wait before I do anything [you] see how it says bother
Good good because I getting so many fucking messages being you can't be blah blah blah because you call him mom. [it's] okay
I'm gonna let this one slide because you are beautiful. Isn't that right Bob what that's a fucking Tom buck
Okay, you might feel a little headache Bob, but that's normal Tomahawk job
It was going so well. Oh, no way. There's a brain in there. Oh, man. I
done
Fuck Bob what?
Oh, we have to cut it off. [oh] shit. Why is not working? I don't get it [ah]
[better] Hurry Up give me the drill [ah]
I'm a professional. I can't work with this
Yeah, ah come on, baby ah fuck this [good]. Hi, what the fuck?
Bob you look so good
Watch what?
You're gonna be so fucking smart after that
We fucking get it this expired. Yeah, I think I put it on right
I don't know. I'm not sure [I] hope you boys enjoy deliever man that your dad is flat I
sound like A man
Crime coming in on your back. I hope you don't mind [I]
[find] none. I like the shakiness of your [mood]. Thank you. I've worked hard on us. What is that cat? [I] think [it]
I got it might be
Can we hump no? We should [not] know humping there's a [wildlife]. I'm sorry. Okay, actually there might be a dog
Loose bits Isaac, Outcry it's a fat dog no it's [a] cow no. No let's just [tell] your [guys] approaching me. Hey cow, hi
Well, we gotta tame the beast now. We can ride him to victory. Oh that would be so awesome
Can you punch it or something series will learn its place. [oh]?
Like yeah, well I can see your face up hood. Yeah
But I don't know what they [measure]
I'm beautiful. Yes, you are you are you?
Okay, [alright]. Let's run with our flashes, and we've got to go with tags on these of flashlights. Yeah, that's our job
I'm ready for this we got to respect the whole fact that there's a freakin zombie apocalypse in months exactly
Are you drunk?
Going there, but screw that going that crap. I'm going this way ma'am. Whoa. I'm right behind your mother
Right okay look at this guy sign on that button
Standing on this button right then man. Thanks. Oh, I got it you fly here you land there in and watch there
I got it before you got it don't worry about [a] cry. Okay. No problem
How do I get back to the portals up then you lie? All [right]? All right?
I was nice fighting in with your side, man. I
Love you, [no]
Thank you to say that
You were supposed to say like don't do it. Whatever you do man. Where's lily?
You'll kill yourself right come on
Standing on this bun. Hey [High-five] Bob don't worry. I'll huff I myself I
Can't do it. [I] cannot do it
Nah, oh, God damn it. I'll find your fucking face
Don't worry your [instinct] is
[that] you back on ken, man, you look
At my boobs pumped up you know yeah
oh
Don't look so conceited. Uh I'm just a pleased to be here fuck you brush
Beauty why are you here aren't you going to spend valentine's they would can try notice the flowers and pointin at them?
those who can
beautiful so um uh
Oh no, he's not for you
cry was astonished
Beauty
What are you trying to say?
I'm trying to say that I I
really like you for a while now and
The King I
may even have more feelings than like and
Won't he be mad. [I] mean sad. I think I love [you]
Beauty I'm lighter that I really am I have to ask about I
Left can do [Mr.]. [down] the floorboards twiddling his thumbs
Why would you leave him you [two] is so happy together? Well it seemed like
Pavilack [Davit], Cry
staring into your life, I
Left her for you. I mean him
Beauty
Miss Yuna you kept me [waiting]
friend
I'm sorry, [oh]
And cry, what is it?
she leaned forward clothes are in clothing [to] cry the
cry
Will you be my valentine?
my life
but
Why go into this building there's the best weapon in the game in this building right here
You rejected [moo]
How dare you?
I
Trusted you do something about it early. Okay? Don't hit me over trust. I [will] try to get you out. [oh], oh
Best weapon in [the] game, huh, best weapon in [the] game, but I see how in it can't for you. So come here
Come here, and free me come in and free me Kayak [cool] [be] cool [be] cool. I'm cool. I'm cool alright
I can't do any big I think you're stuck for [life], okay, stop
you
Attention server, I don't own summer you should kill in the town, so if you look on your map, okay, though
[just] [fuckin] yet. Hope you bros enjoyed this video
Thank you so much to [kay] automation for making it
You can go ahead and check out his channel here and subscribe and for more information. Go ahead and click here
That's all stay awesome bread
God damn this game crap. It is like you need to be a egg, but a lean stein or
Tesla
Your get here is you gotta be shy [riding] here?
Hey, wait your eyes open, okay?
Well yeah, we could get out yeah right listen [guys]
Fuck this home. - yeah
I'm gonna be here. Yeah
I'm ready here. How long you're looking in that and I'll tell my waters are dude. Don't worry by let's go
Through the wrong part of [cry] boy how to find don't worry [about] [it]?
Don't worry about it. Don't worry, right?
So it's fun playing with you. She's like Portal 5
Don't worry about it
Work it work. It work it work
How we oms - we're not we're gonna do the kidney transplant. Yes?
I'll read your brother's comments, and I think we're ready for this shit aren't we bob you're in my domain now, bitch
So a lot of [us] said that you don't want me as your surgeon. Don't make me slap you again
Don't make me slap you. I don't really get what you mean by that. Why isn't it not working Bob?
Why is it not working [in] such a professional [hey] eat it eat it see if I care dick
What don't bite me light saber? Oh shit?
Sorry about [that] Bobby [burn]. [his] nipple little bit nice and easy there we go
Oh shut. Sorry about that Bobby bo, but the delays are go
[wow], not a man but calm down off with the laser off with the laser drill
Did I tell you to start dancing? [no] I did fucking not subscribe this whole thing
Oh, I love your new scarf Bob. [oh], [oh], [you're] fabulous. Love it. I
Was going so well [Bob] what that's right
That's my flapping sound effect [anymore] about holy shit. What the fuck [I]?
Don't want to be a doctor anymore. Nope went off don't you dare fight meg? [oh]?
Yeah
That's right on the bottom you, bitch. [whoo]. Oh, okay, okay? I can actually no they shit. Oh
Oh, don't you die bleed on me Bob? I will fucking kill you if you die
oh
It's in fucking perfect match that [will] make us a perfect matt relax [nerdy] [oh]
[high] [five] that was fucking awesome surgeon complete looks fine to me
I'm sure lip all right next up for [us] brain Transplant that'll be great
Miranda You dirty slut stop calling me
switch
you
Hi, do it Bob how you doin? It's all [gonna] be good. [you're] [in] safe hands
Dr.. Patel, and in in in the house
Yeah
Hi, Bob, you may feel a [slight] pain in your chest area don't worry is normal and if your balls tickle
That's door motor and three one
two
three oh
[but]
That's how we don't want to impair the part-time bitches get out. Oh
What's up? Fuck? Are you the fuck are you that is liver ah are they like cuddling? [it's] not kill
High-five no
You bitch don't make me slap you. I do believe this is how you hold the scissor?
that's how they teach you in school isn't [it] [I] [bob] just gotta [ah]
okay, come on mater ah
All right, let's get the stomach out there you go you don't need [that] shit. Yeah disgusting isn't it Bob Curtis come on, baby?
Don't you dare die on me now, Bob?
yolo mode get a shit in there it said a
10x Fuckin end point s and I tell you [a] 10, what do you want from it come down?
However the analyzer [what]?
Sorry fast
And it's going so well oh
Stop calling me Miranda. [I] don't want to date you
That's [for] bitch. Are you ready for the insertion? Maybe [oh], that's right
Yeah, oh
[nah], what the fuck don't you Darris? It's my insertion what I finger you. What the fuck
see
Gay sounds